I'm gonna start with like a little
introduction of myself I study Earth's
ice sheets and I got interested in this
as a math student as an undergraduate
math student I had the opportunity to
work as an intern on a project about
tipping icebergs and that was really fun
it piqued my interest I came back to New
York and worked at the lamont-doherty
Earth Observatory where I modeled the
ocean floor around Greenland from
gravity data collected by an airplane I
had the opportunity to do field work in
both Greenland and Antarctica and since
becoming a graduate student I worked on
some time series problems some virtual
reality projects and my research
interests have evolved to study not the
bottom of the ice anymore but but the
surface I don't do this by myself this
is a picture of my adviser Robin Bell
and I work with her and many other
scientists and engineers on projects
such as this one this is the ice pod
there are very many scientists and
engineers who are focused on new
techniques for measuring the ice sheets
understanding how they're changing and
figuring out what what causes that
change what are the physical processes
involved in how the ice sheets are are
flowing evolving and losing mass we care
about these regions in the North and the
South
Greenland is the the northern hemisphere
ice sheet Antarctica is the southern
hemisphere ice sheet and together they
contain about 90% of the world's fresh
water out of the United States here for
scale so that you can get a sense of how
much ice is in each in each hemisphere
an ice sheet is a larger area of ice
that's in contact with the rock
underneath and it flows under the force
of gravity by its own weight sort of out
from the center out to the oceans we
care about these areas because together
if all of the ice melted it would raise
sea level by about 65 meters and that
would have implications for the
coastline where most of us live
and as a background to continue the
background anyway I'm gonna talk about
three ways that we know by measuring
from space how the ice sheets are
changing so I'm going to show two videos
the first one all right here we go
so you're zooming in on a region in West
Antarctica called Pine Island glacier
and the first thing you're gonna see is
velocity data from the mid 90s so you
can tell that it's speeding up as time
goes on
and so more ice is flowing from the
middle of the continent out towards the
ocean the second measurement that you
can make from space is height change so
as you go on in time you can see it's a
read of the is a is thinning and as you
go on you can see that the ice sheets
are thinning and they're thinning in the
places that they're that they're flowing
faster so those are two two measurements
that we can make to document the change
there's another one also from satellites
this is this is a satellite that
actually measures of gravity and from
that we can infer mass loss and red
shows a mass loss of blue shows a mass
gain by the way the glacier that you
were looking at before Pine Island is
right here in this area where we know
that a lot of mass is being is being
lost so those are three direct
measurements that that we can make that
that shows change on pretty fast
timescales so I mentioned before that
the ice sheets are grounded on bedrock
but around the edges where they're
flowing out towards the ocean the ice
actually comes up off the rock and is
floating on the water and these are the
areas that I study they're called ice
shelves I've marked three of them here
the Larsen and the Nansen I'm going to
talk about later and then I marked the
Ross here because this is where I got to
go a couple a couple of years ago and
these two diagrams are showing the cross
section of I like a diagram above what
what the ice shelves look like and it's
included the surface melting which is
which is what I study so in the top
panel you're seeing a pattern where ice
is being melt ice is being melted the
water is collecting into ponds and then
there are our crevasses in the floating
part of the ice shelf
or of the ice the ice shelf and the
ponds can can propagate these crevasses
or fractures all the way through to the
ice thickness and break pieces off the
bottom panel shows a different type of
system a different pattern where you
melt the ice maybe you've got some ponds
but actually the water can get
transported long distances by rivers and
these can end up in water falls off the
edge of the of the ice shelf there are
two examples real-world examples of this
the first was probably you might
remember it's kind of a dramatic
dramatic event the Larsen B Ice Shelf in
West Antarctica had been stable for
thousands of years and if you look at
this top image you can kind of see there
are very many ponds that are forming on
the surface there are thousands of these
lakes they're arrayed in a very special
pattern and in 35 days a piece of ice
around the size of Rhode Island
disintegrated and that's because of the
way the student is processing this
diagram that the the ponds are able to
to crack and fracture the ice and if you
have them arrayed in a certain way you
can get disintegration event like this
one recently we've seen evidence for the
other pattern shown in the schematic so
this is the Nansen ice shelf and in this
satellite image you can kind of see that
there are ponds here the same way that
there were in the Larsen B but there's
also a river that runs down transports
water across this shelf and empties it
out into the ocean and this is a picture
of what that of what that waterfall
looks like it's very impressive and
because everybody likes movies I'm gonna
show you a movie of the waterfall so the
the ice shelf is in the background I'll
play it one more time you can see the
the waterfall falling off the shelf and
then in front of that is the ocean it's
just it's covered in an iceberg so so
that's what these things kind of look
like and these two observations have led
to this question Ken rivers by removing
water protect ice shelves
from breaking apart so I'm really
interested in how the spatial pattern of
water on the top of ice shelves can
affect its behavior the way that I think
about this is in terms of a total budget
so you could imagine that the amount of
water that you melt should be equal to
the amount that you store versus the
amount that you remove and today I'm
going to talk about the amount that is
stored and I try to estimate this volume
from satellite images and I do this an
ice shelf in Greenland called Peterman
ice shelf so just to orient you the ice
is flowing from the bottom here towards
the top all of this is the ocean
there are icebergs and it's it's flanked
on either side by by rock ice is flowing
in from the side you can see some ponds
maybe this image is a little bit too
small
but you can see some ponds here there
are also ponds all the way out towards
towards the edge of the shelf there are
two rivers one that runs down the center
line actually there more than two one
main one that runs down the center line
there's a meandering one off to the side
there's another one here and this person
actually did kayak down this main river
that we know empties into a waterfall so
fun or dangerous assignment I'm not
really sure but it happened so to show
you what the data actually look like I
just made a small movie of the area that
was shown in the red box before of how
the water evolves over the course of
about a month in 2016 so I'll played a
couple of times but you should probably
be able to convince yourselves that the
pattern changes in time and pretty
quickly too so you can see lakes that
form and then by the end there are fewer
some of them may be drained some of them
persist I'll play it one more time so in
the beginning there's there's water
everywhere lots of lots of lakes these
ten please disappear really rapidly the
river runs down the middle and so I
think looking at this it's
it's easy to ask yourself well it are
these puns connected the river is the
river draining the water how is the
water how is the water moving there's
clear evidence that it that it is
changing from day to day so looking at
these images as well as reading very
many studies by other people I'm not the
only person interested in this question
this is a big area of research I've I've
kind of broken it up into patterns that
I think we see and that might be
important that might actually like sort
of define and members of a spectrum of
behavior so in Antarctica this is my
little diagram of what the the Larsen B
example would be you have a lot of lakes
there they're spaced in some regular way
and and this is the this is the type
that could could break a break an ice
shelf in Greenland like what I just
showed you there were some bigger lakes
clustered upstream there smaller ones
that are downstream there are fewer
lakes here there are other places in
Antarctica where the lakes are much
bigger but they're concentrated in an
area where you would expect a lot of
melting and then in terms of the river
is both Greenland and Antarctica have
these these rivers that get all the way
to the edge and and end in a waterfall
and they they have really similar shapes
there they're kind of long and linear we
think that they might be there because
of the way that the ice moves and also
the way that the ice interacts with the
ocean
there are also much Wiggly rivers and
I'm not really sure I don't think that
they are controlled by the same process
that that makes the the long skinny ones
so a little bit about the data that I
use you saw some satellite data
yesterday I mostly look at Landsat
images so Landsat is a I guess a
platform that's been collecting imagery
of the earth since the mid 70s the
repeat time is every two weeks so every
two weeks the satellite it's going to
take an image of the same place on earth
the pixel size is about 30 meters so
it's not very detailed but it's good
enough to
measure the changes that I'm seeing and
it looks like this so it comes it takes
measurements across the visible spectrum
and then into the infrared I use just
the visible images so each band is
basically a black and white image of
reflectance as well you turn them into
reflectance values and then you put them
together and you get you get images like
the ones I showed in the in the movie so
this is multi spectral data you can you
can infer a lot about the materials that
you're looking at by investigating all
of the bands that the satellite collects
so one of the things that I do is I take
these images and I try to find out
where's the water
if anybody is familiar with remote
sensing this water classification index
is really similar to the vegetation
index that people use to try to classify
plants so what you do is you take in
this case the blue data on the red data
you do a really simple calculation and
you get a map that that looks like this
middle image and other people have done
this and partitioned the the value or
the range of ndwi values that you can
get into shallow medium and deep water
categories and since I'm after water
volume in this budget this at least
gives you a range of possibilities with
a really really simple calculation the
other thing you can do is knowing what
we know about how light interacts with
water you can come up with a physically
based model that instead of using two
bands you just use one band and you say
well I know about how bright the ice is
I know how bright the water is I know I
can guess what a an infinitely deep Lake
might look like and you can get a map
that looks like this one labeled depth
from color and you can see their their
differences between these two but they
are both picking out the patterns that
your eye would pick out in the visible
image I'm going to talk about some of
the channel
just associated with these mostly in
terms of the ndwi
what I do is I use this classification
and that's kind of a heuristic for
running this depth from color but you
can do one or the other or both okay so
the challenge is associated with this
the ndwi classification misidentifies
shadows as deepwater and just to orient
you again this is the peeterman ice
shelf in Greenland the ocean is over
here ice is flowing from the bottom of
this image to the top this rock over
here is a feud wall and it's casting a
shadow onto the ice these are these are
crevasses so there's water in here too
and it I was actually really surprised
by this because I can tell what a shadow
is and you can tell what a shadow is but
if you actually look at the at the
spectrum like at the at the pixel values
that are recorded here and you do the
ndwi classification they're spectrally
spectrally basically indistinguishable
from each other so this is something
that will completely overestimate the
water storage and we we need to take it
into account one way you can do it is by
just saying okay I'm gonna make a very
conservative mask of how the shadow is
of where the shadow is cast but then you
lose the ability to analyze the nearby
area I've tried to cast the shadow by
knowing something about the elevation
but actually I think the best way to do
this would be to use some kind of
machine learning and like image
segmentation and I'm sure someone in
this room could do it that would be that
would be the a much better way to go
so the ndwi also messes up with miss
identifying different ice surfaces as
shallow water so it's also going to
overestimate the total total volume
stored these two images are of the same
area the first one shows a really bright
ice surface
and it's very clear that this one is
liquid water there are some areas where
if you have a lot of wind the ice
surface that it is exposed is a little
bit blue and hopefully you can hopefully
you can tell that the one on the what is
this both the right side is is overall a
little bit bluer than the one on the
left if you ran the ndwi on this you
would end up with shallow water
everywhere and we don't really think
that that's that that's the case this is
a really difficult this is a really
difficult problem to solve because
optically it's you you can't really tell
a lake that has a that that's totally
liquid from one that just has imagine
like a really thin layer of ice on top
of it you would see right through that
you wouldn't know that it was frozen and
this is where a satellite radar could
come in and actually tell you about the
material properties of the ice but that
involves incorporating a data set at a
different spatial resolution a different
temporal resolution and a fundamentally
different measurement so I think this is
another interesting data science problem
or someone in this room the other thing
is that the atmosphere influences the
the water storage volume estimate and
just to illustrate that point we do a
lot of different corrections in order to
turn the raw data into reflectance value
that has physical meaning and usually
that involves a correction for what's
happening at the top of the atmosphere
and when you do that you get the image
on the your left and I did a simple
calculation for what the effect of the
atmosphere might be and then you get the
image on the right and hopefully you can
see that that one is a little bit redder
if you remember the ndwi incorporates
the red and the blue and if you are
looking at the depth from color equation
I used the red band for that so having
the overall image a little bit shifted
towards the red is is a problem
and in order to solve this you can use a
little some ground truth data but again
you want to be able to do this because
properties that the atmosphere change
every day you'd like to be able to do
this just based on the image so that
you're not making assumptions about what
the atmosphere was like last week and
bringing that into the image that you're
collecting this week the last one is
just trying to figure out what is a lake
and what is a river and this isn't - it
doesn't have to be too difficult it's
the difference between a circle and a
line but the thing is that sometimes the
lakes are elongated and sometimes the
rivers are look a little bit broken up
so a river could actually look like a
bunch of small lakes and a lake could
potentially get miss misidentified as a
river depending on its shape I think
this is another possible machine
learning problem or deep learning
problem I don't know I have a vocabulary
problem
so to bring it back to the to the
original question I'm trying to figure
out how much water is stored on an ice
shelf by looking at at Landsat data and
hopefully I've convinced you that it's
possible but there are some challenges
to overcome
I want to overcome these challenges by
analyzing more satellite data including
ground truth data and then possibly
drawing on the expertise of people in
this room so I'm gonna end with what I
think is another much higher resolution
much more beautiful image of the
peeterman ice shelf thank you to all of
my collaborators and advisors and thank
you for your attention
you